[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to a brand
new TIFF 2019 interview this is for the
movie Saint Maude and I have the team
behind the film right here
first off whoever wants to do this duty
just because everyone out there is not
gonna know what st. modders just yet
what is this movie about it's bound to
have been a couple times today yeah
it's about quite lonely reclusive young
nurse called Maude and she's a living
nurse and she starts caring for her new
patients Amanda Jennifer here but she's
got quite a sort of a strange
relationship with gods on the quick
we've realized there's more to it than
meets the eye and she's she thinks that
God's kind of sending her secret signals
and communications throughout the day
and gets it into her head that she's
been sent to save him and his soul
before she dies that was like you had
prepared that in advance that was an A+
tease no that was perfect
that's a great elevator pitch yeah what
was your very first impression of the
script and what were some of the biggest
questions you had before jumping into
the actual shoot
well I remember first of all very
clearly where I was when my agent rang
me about the script because she was so
excited about it and she likes lots of
scripts but this one just seemed
different
then I remember reading it not know
anything about what it was about but um
have lots of family that working within
the NHS so immediately kind of grabbed
me and then just read it all in one go
really quickly and then just stared at
the ceiling for about an hour
aghast yeah in a good way it was just I
just wanted to do it so much and I
remember after every audition thinking
it was awful my like my auditions
because I wanted it so badly so yeah
immediately I loved it so you get the
role is there a part in a script where
like you're circling and you're like on
that day like I don't know like that is
the most intimidating day for me I think
I just felt very nervous about the whole
thing as I say because it was the first
thing that I've been lead in and but I
think the producers of this film really
took a huge amount of care to make sure
that everyone felt very comfortable in
every department the whole way through
and that
really you just made everything just
seemed so manageable so there wasn't
really once I got there and met everyone
there wasn't I the Terra kind of left me
yeah I was reading that for both of
these roles what you wound up with here
isn't exactly what you initially
pictured so can you tell me a little bit
about the transition from writing these
characters and then finding these two
wonderful it is to bring that role to
screen yeah I mean it's a not in kind of
like radically sort of totally different
but yeah of course that when you're just
having these characters in your head and
you're working on it by yourself so long
you sort of think you've got this very
clear idea and then obviously when you
start sort of seeing and meeting real
people they obviously bring something
completely different I mean I think
maybe initially the kind of like that
age gap was kind of bigger and then I
started just getting nervous
particularly like the Amanda character
so original she was written as English
as well and a little bit older and I
just started to feel that it wasn't my
as I was writing it I think would cost
more for the radio can't remember anyway
um it just felt like I was in danger of
the character going into this slightly
more sort of theatrical kind of Miss
Havisham you sort of thing and you know
this it's about a young woman who kind
of becomes obsessed with this other
woman and she kind of like feels that
they put this sort of strange connection
and so it felt like it should be someone
kind of cooler and sort of more I don't
know so and then just making making her
American as well particularly like
because the character lives in this
weird little kind of seaside town it
just kind of added this extra layer like
how did she get here and there's just
seem a bit more interesting and sort of
meant that both the characters because
more bits well shall we see in
Jennifer's American and they're both in
this English seaside town again it just
gives another little layer from being
Outsiders together and so that was part
of that and then more of the mod
character was I think I did a draft
where it kind of described her as being
like hugely tall or something like this
but I think in my head I was kind like
in the very beginning I don't know again
I think that's one of those things when
you're writing it you're sort of a lot
of some things when you write them Danno
things become more nuanced when you get
actual people sort of doing it so I
thought as I was writing it I felt like
there needed to be something sort of
quite distinctive about the way she
looked that sort of made her sort of
stick out a bit it just said we started
looking down that route in the casting
and it just didn't just
sort of work it's sort of realized
actually no she kind of needs to be
somebody that can sort of hide and blend
in a bit more and I think you would like
the last person we saw as well pretty
much like at first I was kind of like
thinking on her then you came in to tell
me about joining this project because we
spoke earlier this year for the wolf
hour and I just get really excited when
I see a very familiar face that I
imagine could get just about any project
she wants picking up all these really
interesting things so even though this
project and that two entirely different
films is there something that
consistently needs to stay the same from
opportunity to opportunity to kind of
draw you in oh that's an interesting
question I I think well both those films
actually that because you they are
wildly different but they both do very
much have their own world aesthetically
and I think part of more faith being
Welsh and me being American and being in
that seaside town it it helps create
that that that world where there kind of
that rose takes us into that's very very
different I don't know I just I just
love when you read us voice like roses
that so I don't know there's a there's a
core of confidence to you into your work
that is it's just really exciting and
rich and you could really feel it on the
set that right from the beginning that
we were all there - we were all there
because of rose and you don't always get
that feeling working on a job that
absolutely every single person just
wanted to help her realize this to the
best of their ability I could feel that
so much just reading the press notes
there were so many people who gave
quotes that said from your prior work
from film school right that everybody
wanted to back you make this thing
happen for you because they believed in
you to backtrack a little bit because we
talked about this often I find that
people are always asking like should I
go to film school is it worth the money
or should I just go out and get
experience just from your perspective
what would you say to someone who is
wondering whether or not that path is
right for them it's a really tricky one
to say because I'm gonna be some of it
so much
comes into you know if you can get the
funding to go there in the first place
so I sort of don't want to be kind of
like you must go to film school like I
think that it's an initially well
there's there are a lot of different
routes into it I think I had a great
time at the film schools I went to go
fantastic I'm sure I wouldn't sort of be
doing what I am now particular sort of
maybe as soon as I did but I haven't
gone there but but also I don't know
there's there's but they're not arguably
going to film school also it's
definitely not for everyone because I
think it's hard to teach any creative
subjects it's a great school but you do
get the flip side of it is that you do
get slightly you can get a bit sort of
entrenched in kind of right this is how
you do this and do that and gets you a
bit uptight in a way so in a way like
the years since going out of film school
part but it's been sort of loosening
some of that up a bit and being like
okay well that's a way of doing
something and realizing gee so I mean
arguably and if you don't go through the
film school route potentially might be
more conducive to kind of finding a more
unique about feeling out your own path
but kind of applying what you just said
it to this movie in particular was there
any situation where you said to yourself
like this is how I'm gonna shoot this
scene and then there was that happy
magic on sentence something came out of
it that you didn't plan for
oh yeah loads but now obviously my
brains completely blanking some kind of
way I mean I going into a particularly
the visual style and kind of how I was
shooting things I do have fairly sort of
clear idea in my head of how it should
all look even as I'm writing it and sort
of where the cuts are and that sort of
thing and like before every day's
shooting you know we'll have the shot
list already in there me and Ben fort
psmith GIP kind of going on going okay
we start here we go but I think I like
having that much preparation so that
then if stuff does come up she can kind
of move around it you and Ben have such
a good relationship in terms of I think
when we all came on set you already knew
what you were doing so we went we didn't
feel like we had to be yeah I hope you
guys never cause of the Seaview kind of
got a clearer idea of okay we'll go here
and here but you need to bother see
we're kind of doing a scene and it's
like oh isn't right then you should be
able to change stuff and prioritize that
it's obviously should be led by the
performance of all the actors doing but
it's but wishy-washy answer me
you yourself more credit do you - I want
to know a little bit about your
collaboration because we don't get to
see too often two characters where one
brings something out of the other so
much it's like I couldn't learn more
about one by herself you needed to be a
pair here so what were the kind of
conversations you had jumping into that
I don't know we ever talked about I feel
like there was maybe half an out like
half an hour or something in your
dressing room it's a little at one point
before like the start of the shoot
because you come to England so shortly
before we did I know we talked but I
think there was so much in the script I
didn't feel it was so clear I thought in
my mind who Maude was and who like I had
I had a clear idea of who Amanda was and
then when I met Jennifer which is like
so I don't think we consciously were
like let's talk about this it was just
kind of sometimes it can be you know
sometimes if you talk in a situation
like this too much you can even out the
if it's nice to have your secrets
especially with something where there -
such very individual and lonely people
it's kind of nice to for each one to
kind of keep your mystery a little bit
and sometimes it's nice not to kind of
let the other to share too much about
with the other actor about what you're
expecting and also I think it was so
clear in the script and again we trusted
rose so there's also two characters who
aren't supposed to know each other at
the beginning of the film and a big part
of it is them sort of finding stuff out
about each other so I thought it was
quite I mean I think the first scene we
shot was sort of Maude's first day sort
of taken care of Amanda and I think
obviously adding - first day on shoot
neither of us knew each other very well
it gives things a slight change it does
that's kind of how what is when she
turns up sitting here with a bunch of
wonderful women can you tell me a little
bit about just the experience I mean
this is a very broad question but just
the experience of like all uniting
together as female filmmakers making
something that we might not have been
able to see a little while ago that's
great yeah it's it's exciting there was
just so much respect for everybody on
CERN I think that's kind of what's
important when discussing any of this
stuff about kind of feminism or
everything
that you have to have just respect for
everyone do you know not kind of
platform people but like be extra
careful with someone for a particular
weakness of great men as well yeah but
just the whole it was just it really was
love you I don't think I could have I
would have struggled doing such a part
if that wasn't the environment that I
was doing in and like particularly with
Jennifer like Jennifer was just so
nurturing and lovely to me in this and
it was just so important I didn't
realize until afterwards how different
it could have been say if we hadn't
clicked or some things and yeah before
we have to wrap up because you speak so
highly of just the whole environment on
set if you had a name one unsung hero of
st. Maude who would it be anyone from
from a PA to I love you passed this
question before I love my questions
because we never talk I mean we were
talking earlier in another interview
about a caterer who made a difference on
one day I can't pick one person out I
feel - I feel too bad sing this that's
you guys choose it's it is it's really
hard to pick someone out I think for me
it would have if I I don't think she's
an unsung hero at all but if I Jack Etta
who did my hair and makeup I think it
wouldn't have been Amanda without her
but I don't consider her a nun we had a
wonderful props guy but everybody was
amazed Tina who did the costumes yeah
Justin I mean she's the makeup effects
but there's one particular scene on this
that I'm not gonna spoil for anyone out
there but I applaud that it was so well
done yeah it's a good one isn't it yeah
Oh which one Tina's already won B the
question is well she's she's fantastic
and she's completely mad and brilliant
and we she's very sort of patient with
me because there's that there's a key
sort of costume towards the end the film
it kind of sank you
which we didn't in the script it was
like completely different to what it is
there and she made this thing which I've
sort of asked her to and it all came
together fantastically I would say
Jackson and Simone who were the runners
as well because I fell down the stairs
in the first day and it was like
slightly incapacitated and they just
looked after me so much so yes they were
shaders there were a lot of spirits we
had a fire escape and honestly I've
never been looked up with such concern
falling down the stairs
I went came out in a scene towards the
end where I look rather upsetting
potentially and we had this long fire
escape down the side of the building we
had to go to lunch at the building next
door
and I went down stairs and there was a
little boy and he burst into tears when
he saw me and like turned his head and
then Jennifer told me I think Jennifer
told me that does it oh that's so sad
and then like yes yes oh I hate to say
goodbye but I have to let you go
thank you for having me enjoy your time
at if c-minor even I am for it also a
huge thank you to our wonderful sponsors
over at Nordstrom Canada thank you for
making these interviews happen do not
leave without liking and sharing this
video and stay tuned for more coverage
from TIFF 2019